when he spoke today the president did
not take questions so he didn't get to
explain why just a few weeks ago he was
telling us that the pull out from
afghanistan would look nothing like
saigon in 1975.
the taliban is not the south of the
north vietnamese army they're not
they're not remotely comparable in terms
of capability there's going to be no
circumstance where you see people being
lifted off the roof of a
embassy in the of the united states from
afghanistan it is not at all comfortable
brit hume is our senior political
analyst he's analyzed a lot of politics
over many years we're happy to have him
here thanks so much for coming on
tonight so how do you assess the
politics of this for the administration
well i think this is a stain
it's unmistakable the viewpoints across
the board
uh of this evacuation operation of the
pull-out the last piece of the pull-out
have been uniformly the same that it's a
disaster that it was horribly planned it
was misbegotten the intelligence was bad
the judgment was bad and the decision to
do it like this was worst of all yes and
you're hearing that from all quarters
now and i think as people look at these
images the images will stay in people's
minds i mean that pathetic scene on that
tarmac today with people chasing that
airplane grabbing on some falling off i
mean people won't forget that and it
will be a stain on joe biden and his
record that i think will endure now it
will fade to some extent as things will
the best thing he has going for him
right now is possibly the fact that once
the taliban really secure control of the
place the amount of reporting we get out
of there may be very limited we may not
know the extent of atrocities that are
being committed
or the subjugation of women and all the
things that uh that we try it's possible
they will make their people wear masks
you know cover their faces
yeah yeah back to the burqas that's
possible um so
you gotta think so i have been
frustrated for a long time that we're
still there that's my personal view we
should leave 20 years to long et cetera
et cetera
and i still feel that way so i'm glad
we've left but there's got to be some
non-humiliating non-chaotic
non-disastrous way to leave right i mean
the real issue today the thing that
biden rather cleverly talked about in
political terms was he talked about that
the decision was withdraw
well that ship kind of sailed a long
time ago we've been gradually
withdrawing from there for years and all
that was in question was when the final
pull out of the final remaining soldiers
will be there the mission of of nation
building which everyone now seems to
agree was a mistake that has been
abandoned for years we've been drawing
down our forces but the other thing
we're doing there's a nation building
again a nation built with 2 500 troops
for god's sake you know we were there as
kind of military support for the afghan
forces which seemed to be motivated by
not just supported by but very much
motivated by our presence there you know
and they despite all the criticism that
biden leveled at them today they fought
long and hard and lost tens of thousands
of
of soldiers killed yes fighting the
taliban
so
there is that but
this question this issue was all about
how you execute the final pull out
and this was unmistakably hideously
botched were you surprised by it
considering
i was well you know you hear these
people say this they say you know we got
a handle on this we know and
and all the rest of it right and you
know i wasn't as excited about the pull
out as some others were i may have a
disagreement about that
but as for this the execution of this
piece of it it's a disaster that and
look that's what he inherited he
inherited a drawn-down force about to be
removed right from afghanistan his job
was to remove it safely and effectively
right
and
the consequences of his decision-making
about how to do that are what we saw
today and yesterday
this is on him this piece of it is on
him
i wonder if he'll be recorded that way
well i don't at the at this point
to my somewhat to my surprise
um
we're seeing it reported that way now
you know i'm beginning to see traces of
people saying well the american people
really broadly support the withdrawal
and he's trying to change the subject to
all we're talking about was the decision
to withdraw and so on
um but
this i think still leaves an indelible
mark harder to get these images yeah and
i don't see any sign of competence i
mean look at our cities they're not good
at it britain i appreciate you're coming
on you bet tucker thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else